[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguna vez te has sentido totalmente
solo en el mundo
como que no tenías nadie a tu lado
les quiero pedir que cierren sus ojos
por un momento
recuérdate cuando cumpliste 18 años
cómo te sentiste
[Música]
quizás estabas con mucha emoción alegría
quizás tenías miedo
quizás estaba terminando el colegio
entrando leonesidad
quién tenías a tu lado en ese momento
ahora recordarte el momento en que te
sentiste totalmente independiente por
primera vez
que ya no dependía de tus papás de tu
familia ya estabas un adulto mayor
cómo te sentiste quién estaba a tu lado
ahora pueden abrir sus ojos
levanta tu mano si en estos momentos
tenias por lo menos una persona
acompañando t
ahora levanta tu mano
si en ambos momentos si ambos momentos
eran el mismo que cuando cumpliste 18
años también era la primera vez que te
sentiste independiente por primera vez
son muy pocos bueno
ahora les quiero contar la historia de
un joven que conozco que se llama
gustavo
gustavo a muy temprana edad tenía que
entrar al sistema de protección
porque su familia le abandonó
primero entró al salmón klain un lugar
de niños pequeños después lo llevaron a
otro hogar donde pasó casi todo su
infancia
pero a la edad de 17 años este hogar
cerró entonces lo llevaron a otro hogar
de niños que era uno de galp estatal
para esperar su cumpleaños de 18 años
cuando ya tenía que dejar el centro
ahora les voy a pedir una vez más que
cierren sus ojos
imagínate que tú eres gustado en este
momento
cómo se siente saber que ya llega tu
cumpleaños de los 18 años y eso
significa que ya tienes que salir del
hogar y enfrentar el mundo ser
independiente por primera vez
entrar a un mundo que no conoces
apuesto que se siente bastante diferente
a como tú te sentiste cuando ibas a
cumplir 18 años
pueden abrir sus ojos
esta es la cruda realidad para que hace
tres millones de niños 10 al docentes
que viven en el sistema de protección en
el mundo
aquí en bolivia son 30.000 mil niños y
desde los entes que viven en centros de
acogida a nivel de bolivia
es una realidad muy poco conocido que a
los 18 años estos niños después de estar
en estos centros muchos porque así todas
sus vidas tienen que dejar estos centros
al ser abandonados y abandonados ya una
vez por sus familias
están abandonados otra vez por el estado
que ya es su familia legal
muchas veces enfocamos en los niños
pequeños que viven en los hogares
orfanatos como muchos nos conocemos
pero poco pensamos en la situación de
los jóvenes que salen de estos centros y
a dónde van y qué apoyo reciben
pero qué pasa si estos jóvenes reciben
un acompañamiento que no están solos en
este momento tan grande en sus vidas
que pueden caminar junto con alguien en
este proceso y no sentirse solos en el
mundo
qué diferencia podría hacer
hay estudios que dicen que la soledad
es un mayor riesgo a la salud pública
que la obesidad
qué sentirte solo en el mundo de sentir
que no te perteneces a ningún lado que
no tienes un lugar en el mundo
es un riesgo muy grande a la salud de
una persona y es muy común demasiado
porque les estoy contando esto
bueno como ya saben yo no soy de aquí de
bolivia yo crecí en australia
con una familia amorosa una familia que
me acompañaban en todo yo me sentí muy
afortunada
y lleno de amor y cariño toda mi vida
entonces por eso es fuerte que tenía mi
vida a mis 18 años yo decidí irme áfrica
a salvar el mundo
yo tenía la idea de que por ser una
persona afortunada significa que yo
tenía el poder y el derecho de sentir
que yo sabía mejor que las personas
pobres
y que fue mi trabajo de ir a salvarles a
mostrarles el camino
estaba equivocada evidentemente no
pero lo que aprendí en este momento en
áfrica que pasé cuatro meses en
diferentes comunidades
era lo que me lleva aquí hoy día
que no es
mi trabajo de tener que ayudar a las
personas porque las personas mismas se
puede hacerlo
lo que yo puedo hacer como una persona
es acompañarles compartir mostrar
compasión tratar de ofrecer lo que yo
tengo de recursos en conocimiento en
amor
para quizás hacer una pequeña diferencia
para por lo menos una persona
eso es lo que
yo aprendí en áfrica
el hecho de empoderar
de ayudar pero no en el hecho de que yo
sé mejor que ellos
el hecho de que en realidad ellos saben
y quizás solo necesitan sentirse
acompañados y escuchados
entonces yo llegué aquí a bolivia hace
10 años fue mi mi aniversario en junio
este año
llegué
para poder hacer un voluntariado en un
centro de niños de acogida
y lo que dije ahí
eran niños que por ninguna culpa de
ellos mismos estaban en una situación de
tener que vivir en un centro de tener
que vivir dentro en una institución en
vez de vivir con una familia
y eso no me pareció justo para nada
lo que también
pase cuando yo estaba en áfrica
en bolivia perdón es que yo vi a mi mamá
en los niños con quien estaba trabajando
porque mi mamá a sus 3 años fue
abandonada por su mamá
y yo crecí
viendo
el dolor
el rechazo el abandono que ella se
sintió toda su vida
que ella sufrió la sensación de que no
merecía amor porque su propia mamá no la
quería
y entonces de alguna forma cuando llegué
aquí a bolivia y pasé tiempo en estos
niños
sentí que yo quizás podría quitar un
poco de este dolor de ellos que no nunca
podría lograr quitar de mi mamá
entonces en este momento fundé una
fundación que es la fundación que ahora
tengo
y decidí que fue mi mi lucha de tratar
de hacer una pequeña diferencia para
estos niños
entonces ahora quiero volver a gustavo
[Música]
que cuando yo lo conocí tenía sus 18 17
años y ya estaba por cumplir sus 18
y estaba esperando para ver qué iba a
ser después de salir del centro
y yo digo afortunadamente por él
estábamos con mi fundación trabajando en
el centro donde él estaba entonces
teníamos la oportunidad de trabajar con
él y acompañarle
en su proceso de transición de dejar el
centro
cuando lo conocí fue un joven muy
dinámico abierto bastante divertido pero
también también en cierto de su futuro
de donde iba a llegar
y por suerte lo que lo que podríamos
ofrecerle era justo escucharle y
acompañarle en su camino para que él
pueda decidir dónde quiere ir en su vida
entonces me da mucha alegría decirles
que ahora gustavo es un joven bastante
exitoso ya vive con otros jóvenes que
han pasado por nuestros programas en una
fundación
que está estudiando tiempo completo está
trabajando tiene muchos amigos es un
joven bien responsable
y me siento muy orgulloso de lo que él
ha podido lograr
pero qué podría haber pasado si él
estaba solo en este proceso como hay
muchos jóvenes que pasan por esta
experiencia que no tienen a nadie cuando
salen de estos centros están totalmente
solos muchos de ellos por los estudios
se muestra que llegan a la calle no
tienen trabajos o encuentran trabajos
que las explotan mucho
entran a usar las drogas el alcohol
puede ser que se embarazan de muy
temprana edad y sus propios hijos
vuelvan al mismo sistema en que ellos
han salido y así se repite el ciclo
pero qué diferencia hace cuando hay
alguien ahí
escuchándoles apoyándoles creyendo en
ellos
puede hacer toda la diferencia para
todo ser humano y me incluyo como ya
hemos escuchado hoy buscamos conexión
buscamos amor
buscamos sentirnos parte de algo que no
nos pertenecemos a algún lugar
es parte de ser humanos que buscamos esa
conexión
les quiero terminar contando una
historia que se llama en la historia de
la estrella
hola hola me escucha bueno
y tecnología
bueno les estaba contando la estrella de
mar alguien ha escuchado ya de esta
historia
si no lo vas a contar por favor a los
demás
baa si un día hay un joven mayor un
mayor que está caminando por la playa y
a la instancia ve a un joven también
caminando por la playa
y acercándose un poco más al joven ve
que el joven está agarrando estrellas de
mar que están por toda la costa y
lanzándoles para devolverle hasta el
agua
entonces el mayor hombre mayor se pone
curioso y se acerca al joven irse
disculpe joven
qué exactamente estás haciendo
el joven mira y dice bueno hay muchas
estrellas de mar aquí si no les devuelva
el agua van a morir porque el sol está
bien fuerte
y el hombre dice
y bueno me parece muy lindo muy bien
pero temo decirle que hay miles de
estrellas de mar en esta playa cómo va a
lograr hacer una diferencia
y el joven agarró una estrella de mar
más lo tira de la opción y dice
ha sido una diferencia para este
creo que muchas veces nosotros nos
sentimos que el mundo es muy grande y
los problemas que hay en el mundo son
demasiados grandes para que podemos
hacer una diferencia que podemos tener
un impacto a veces hasta ponemos excusas
no no tengo tiempo estoy muy ocupado
no tengo las habilidades ni los
conocimientos que puede aportar
lo que yo les quiero decir es que cada
uno de ustedes tiene la habilidad de
hacer una diferencia en este mundo
que sea solo para una estrella de mar
a una persona que conocen en su vida
a un gustado que me alegre decir que
está aquí con nosotros hoy
todos tenemos la habilidad de hacer esta
diferencia
no quiero que me aplaudan a mí
quiero que aplana me ha gustado
gracias